yeah I was a bad guy I was a bad guy
wait what do you mean like just I don't
think I was a nice person oh really yeah
yeah you were just you were angry you
were just behind the scenes like with
the camera cut on I'll be nice to you
right now but I'm tired of it you might
[ __ ] I [ __ ] Danny really yeah so I
think it was a lot of people that was
like man [ __ ] that [ __ ] really but I
was going at the time I had a huge lean
addiction
ah what's I'm addicted to opiates so
when I'm not when I'm not at the crib
and I'm not drinking lean [ __ ] all
day
yeah so if I'm a New York and I got to
do [ __ ] interviews all [ __ ]
weekend and I can't find lean I'm
[ __ ] sick I mean it's not it's not in
the black plan that's an excuse I'm not
using this excuses it's [ __ ] up for me
to be like that yeah so I would always
just be edgy and just I would mean to
people man I was real I was a real bad
guy what's lean like it's amazing what
like give me lean explain lean oh man
hit that
so good yeah can you imagine like I mean
an adult candy like the it just tastes
so good they just eat candy once you get
addicted to The Taste it's it's it like
engulfs your life almost like you can
just be anywhere next you know just
tasting your mouth like [ __ ] wait read
me I'm just mean like Cravings you know
you get cravings for food but you got
lean Cravings all the time if you don't
have it and what is the high oh it's
amazing man you just
you love life man you listen to music
and go to sleep
it's just opiate man just not out you
know heroin just I know I mean one time
I listened to a Chief Keef song 2700
times straight
2700. that's exactly that's the actual
number yes I swear to God I can't make
this it was 27 something but they're
actually that's what I knew like this is
crazy what song was it bro young Rambo
you better know that [ __ ] word for words
how many minutes are in a day it's only
like two minutes no I think it's like
two days bro yeah I remember buying I
had a paneling I remember getting it I
pulled up
but don't you keep that on my headphones
and I remember just once I finally got
out it was like piece of boxes
everywhere KFC boxes just the whole room
was in shambles and then my lean was
gone and it was like then I was just
finally like Snapped out of it and I
like took a shower and [ __ ] I was like
what the [ __ ] just happened I'm like
it's Sunday whoa that [ __ ] was Thursday
night
wow that's what I was like oh this is
bad yeah when do you start reflecting on
you having an addictive personality and
being self-destructive with that oh I've
always known that so you just you've
known it and you're like I'm gonna
submit to this sometimes
I mean like I said the best thing for me
is just not to have it a part of my life
you know me being Detroit bro we'll be
bad fall back I don't call it it was all
bad have you tried every drug
no no I don't do crack I never did crack
I knew that meth I never did heroin
everything else is negotiable
LSD what I saw my whole world crumble
all [ __ ] asset man what do you mean
I did ask it one time
and you know you see like Roman Empires
or whatever it's like castles and [ __ ]
like a whole [ __ ] and everything just
like Game of Thrones type [ __ ] and it
was like I was like a king in a castle
or some [ __ ] but the whole [ __ ] just
started crumbling like destroying and
then I remember like
that you know how you have to you know
that big ass ball in front of Target I
had one of those in the castle and I
remember that's the last thing I saw
it's like smoke everything is destroyed
and that seen that one big ball killer
just bouncing like boom boom then it
projected me out and then I was able to
see a whole overview of what the city
was and everything was [ __ ] burning
and all [ __ ] up it was like a dragon
that made me decide to move to Austin
Texas because it gave me my because I
always thought to myself what did that
mean
does that mean it's over for me in
Detroit this is over for me here like I
need to get the [ __ ] out of here bro or
you give what I'm saying I swear to God
that was one of like the biggest so I
asked the trip was like yeah I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here man it's over for
me here like um it's destroyed
everything is you know
as it seems like he can either really
change your life for the better and make
you realize things or completely ruin
everything for your future like some
people have a bad trip and then they're
just [ __ ] forever at you yeah yeah
that's just a little crazy and then some
people are like no I changed my whole
life I had a big Revelation because I
asked it I think it's all about where
you at mentally when you take it and
what you're doing it for it's fun
therapy what you doing it for yeah you
know because some people do it to have
fun but some people are doing it for
actually like you know therapy type
reason like trying to figure some [ __ ]
out so it's all about what you're doing
it for a kind of you know like me when I
was doing the um like I just like I said
I did a [ __ ] quarter pound of
mushrooms in like a month
and what was my purpose of doing that it
just was
I don't know I just was trying to figure
out where my life was at today and you
said you saw death yeah I saw my actual
grave and it made me not scared of death
anymore but yeah you said that earlier
why why are you not scared of death
anymore because it taught me that that's
the graduation of life when when it's
time for you to be picked for that [ __ ]
to happen it was you did what you had to
do on this on this situation but that
don't mean it ends though something
about that said it didn't like it made
me feel like it didn't end why like I
don't know because that's what you feel
about death is the permanence of it
I think I was just scared of death
because so many people around me was
just dying so young like you know in
retina I love so many friends or like
you know and you feel like a lot of
people I've Just Seen A lot of people
die young bro and so you feel like they
didn't accomplish what they need to
accomplished but then that showed you
they've accomplished everything in this
graduation time
so it's like man when you when it's time
when they call you you did what you had
to do so so you'd be cool if you died
today I think I did what I had to do wow
and where do you think you go after you
die
you come back
well how do you come back
like full reincarnation I mean I
wouldn't say reincarnation are you going
to come back as a frog yeah dummy yeah
it does death I think that's the hell
when they talk about like hello on Earth
uh you're like a mosquito yeah when you
get reincarnated as a mosquito you're a
lantern fly it's a white chick the whole
religion is is hell yeah bro what does
that mean
you know other religions have hell also
you know yeah yeah but like in Danny
Brown's World your religion is Hell
reincarnation is hell no he said come
back right or a spotted lantern
that happens in your religion that's
hell yeah but hell also happens in other
religion that would be your point
[Laughter]
that would be your punishment for not
doing what you're supposed to do on this
physical Place ah so if you come back as
a frog or something [ __ ] up he's
showing you like me uh this [ __ ] ain't
cool but if you live a good life you
come back as another person yeah do you
think that in a better in a better form
of yourself
like a software update oh that's crazy
so if you if you were to die
if you would have died today all the
drugs he had to do just to be in this
yeah it's crazy what are you coming back
as if you were to die today
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah
so you basically gonna come back as your
girl yeah
you won't [ __ ] so bad here yeah
I really feel like he ain't gonna let me
come back as a [ __ ] man he gonna be
like duh this [ __ ] gotta feel it he got
to know what the other side feels like
yeah
let me see what this [ __ ] is on yeah I'm
coming back as a puppet so then I have
more empathy yeah
there you go so what type of dudes would
you [ __ ]
I want to feel secure
this [ __ ] got guns everywhere [ __ ] I'm
one of them type of [ __ ] man like
this [ __ ] got cause he dangerous
he's dangerous
cause swear I can't make this up I
believe you no I don't think you're
making it up
I can't date that dude he's a square
Ain't No Square [ __ ] in my life that
[ __ ] too boring being with a regular
[ __ ]
but this [ __ ] man let's come back
watching sports and [ __ ] yeah I'm that
guy I'm very boring yeah but me too
though I don't know no no no no no no no
no
no
wait I don't buy that you're blind it
comes in increments I literally sit
around and play video games all day when
you're not addicted to drugs yeah I'm
not addicted to drugs I do drugs
when I'm at home I'm not doing when I'm
at home with my girl you said you were
addicted to lean is what I'm referring
oh that was years ago though it's too
expensive
is the most expensive dog to do anybody
that's doing lean they're just doing it
as a stunt because it's not even worth
the money you're paying for it and the
lean that I did it got it got
discontinued because Justin Bieber is oh
really what happened activists
well this is the story I don't know if
this is real but they saying it's a
great way to start a story but they're
saying Justin Bieber overdosed on only
activated diet type [ __ ] activist is the
name of the name of the brand it's still
a drug coming they make other [ __ ] they
just don't make lean no more yeah yeah
and um it was the best tasting [ __ ] ever
really
I used to just and you know the thing
about lean is you got to drink a lot of
soda like I'll be at the grocery Market
yeah you got sugar looking at all the
rarest you know drinking a two liter a
day
uh bad [ __ ] so what happened was
activists ain't want that on their name
that's what the lean gut is yeah it's
not the leaves
and it makes you constipated
uh I think it's just mad turd sitting in
yourself
so yeah I think they say the overdose on
activists and they didn't want that
blood on their name so yeah
if you buy lean now that lean literally
tastes like candy you didn't taste no
medicine after taste so if you drink
lean now it has a medicine after uh it
doesn't taste good but now these kids
say that's what they want how much is
like a bottle of lean now oh it's I
think it's 5 500 a line what's a line
mean an ounce so like damn you know
so to buy a pint I think it's 16 ounces
in a pound so it's 8 000 for a pint of
lean
damn like I've drunk I drunk all the
other leans the Morton Grove the [ __ ]
whatever but you like the activists I
was really addictive actor yeah
would you say that's like the white
women of lean
[ __ ] that's the Mamacita
these [ __ ] drinking a white [ __ ] that
was a Telemundo